[Music]
all right
hello i'm kelly i'm a professor at cal
poly it's about three and a half hours
south of here
um and i'm going to tell you about some
stuff we are building
five minutes so welcome to my
infomercial here we go
so here is the thesis by which my
collaborator hunter and i
started this project things are hard and
things are extra hard for teachers
because teachers have
no time for things and no resources
sometimes for things like personal
development and r studio conferences
so we're like how can we use r to make
it easier for the other people in our
field
so we have two packages that are in
infancy um and these two packages i'm
going to give you like the shortest
possible sneak preview
and then i'll tell you more about the
one that's not in infancy
so here's the thing that's hard if you
are a basic r user and i mean basic
probably
beyond anyone at this conference many of
our collaborators our colleagues
they use r they know it by which i mean
they can like read in data and run a
linear model
not much else and they're very excited
about shiny but
the whole idea of shiny is very
intimidating
so we're working on a package that the
idea is can we like
boil shiny down to something accessible
by people at this very basic level
so the basic idea is to have some kind
of pipeline maybe that creates the app
for you that writes the skeleton code
again we have some of this running but
it's not public yet
and we're very open to other ideas as
well thinking about ways to make it
easier
the second thing that's hard is updating
course materials every single year you
have to like change all the little
details in your syllabus even if the
structure of it didn't change much
so package number two is called templar
for templates and the idea is templating
is really cool in our studio and our
markdown
so one thing is there's package
templates so you could auto generate
all the subfolders of your course file
and it would fill in the course name in
the right places
and then it would populate those folders
then with our markdown template files
that use
yaml to kind of automate filler so this
is a syllabus example
made it as big as i could and get
everything in there but the idea is
the information that changes um quarter
to quarter year to year
you would just change in the yaml
everything else you could leave alone
and maybe it's even gonna write
you know tables and stuff automatically
for you
alright so that's your sneak preview but
what i'm here to mostly tell you about
is flare
player is a package that
i'm very excited about so this is
something that maybe applies to everyone
in this room
formatting source code for presentations
i've seen a lot of presentations today
people are showing their source code
sometimes what you want to do is things
like highlight the important parts of
your source code
right but this is very frustrating
sometimes there's several problems with
it
one is just the annoyance of what most
people do what i used to do is
copy paste the r code into like
powerpoint and manually highlight things
or what have you perhaps more
importantly to this community
it's not reproducible i don't know if
you have done this i have done this in
class where i
decide to tweak something and i forget
to tweak it in the powerpoint or
whatever
and then my students are seeing code
that doesn't match the graph that's not
great
so this is how i feel
and so we like to introduce flare
because you are adding kind of
meaningless decoration it does not
change how the code runs and it does not
change the
internal um i don't know value of the
code
and so how it works very briefly you
have your code chunk nothing in this
code chunk is new
except that it's very important that you
give it a name and important probably
that you turn off include unless you
want it to be duplicated
and so yeah we all have iris i only have
five minutes i can't tell you about new
data sets so
suppose this is my code chunk that's
what it looks like step two
is you call this decorate function that
kind of preps that code chunk to be
flared
and then all you have to do is add the
flare that you want to this code chunk
so there's a whole suite of flare
functions the basic one is just like
directly flare a string
and then the other ones we've got some
shortcuts for like highlighting
functions and stuff
so you might end up with something like
this if you're trying to teach piping
here's the functions that you're piping
too
there's my pipes and we learn exciting
new things about flowers
so that's it that's all it takes there's
a lot more that i would love to tell you
about
but that's the main deal so i just
because there's no questions i want to
answer
some things that you might want to know
does it work in
all the like our markdown spin-offs
mostly yes
these are in share engine obviously i
used flare to flare my flare but
um uh there is kind of a little
complication where we sort of have to
hard code the way code gets formatted
that's not the same for every doctype so
all you've got to do is tell me what
doctype you want and i can easily add
that in
but i have to know about that doctype to
make it work
what happens when you so this is for
knitting right we want the knitted code
to look good what happens when you just
run it
actively first of all any code that you
have if you've chosen to leave evaluate
on
it it does run so you can like reference
objects
and it previews how it's going to flare
in your viewer pane so you can check
that without knitting
latex is the next order of business
crayon was going to be on two months ago
and then i woke up at 3am with a whole
plan
of how to rebuild everything better so
imminently is the hope on cran
it's just about there um and that's all
i have to say
so
oh tech stickers sorry
hat stickers are on the chair at the end
if you want them
you